Britain's Queen Elizabeth is revealing
secrets about the day she was crowned
nearly 65 years ago the Queen was
interviewed for a documentary that will
air on the Smithsonian Channel this
Sunday in the program she also watches
film footage of her coronation in June
1953 Charlie d'Agata is outside
Westminster Abbey in London where that
historic moment happened charlie good
morning good morning
well Westminster Abbey really hasn't
changed much since Queen Elizabeth was
crowned here but she has changed and so
has the monarchy and this documentary
shows the Queen and what she felt about
that day in a way we really haven't seen
before imagine if you can young Queens
feelings we no longer have to imagine
for the first time the Queen is sharing
those feelings herself and while a
journey and a gold coach may have looked
like something out of a fairy tale
apparently it was a bumpy ride and it's
just one of the candid secrets unveiled
in the coronation where Her Majesty
regales viewers with fond memories of
the day she was crowned nearly 65 years
ago I mean I've seen one coronation have
been the recipient it's a sign of the
Queen we rarely see says royal
correspondent Roy Anika I think we often
forget the Queen is a human like the
rest of us because we so rarely hear
from her in a personal way this was just
a very young woman like a lot of other
young men but just taking you on a roll
that was like nothing else any other
experience such fun for the children
that meant to do and it comes as the
Royals ride a wave of popularity but
with the success of the crown on Netflix
baby number three on the way for William
and Kate this spring and of course the
star-studded wedding between the
ever-popular Prince Harry an American
beggin Markel there is so much
enthusiasm and spotlight on the monarchy
at the moment and they seem to be having
a sort of burgeoning Renaissance of
popularity not just in the UK but
actually around the world
so the anniversary the coronation this
summer is just one cause for celebration
in what has become a very busy year for
the royal family and the champagne will
be flowing Norah I like the idea of a
renaissance
Charlie d'Agata in London thank you